there was a ukrainian open miker that
dm'd me four days ago
why why i mean why are you why is that
coming out now i mean i don't even know
if he speaks that well of english i
looked up his videos it's all in uh did
he did he tmu in english it was very
broken though uh let me let me check my
dms see what he's up to get him right
now we got to reach out to these people
ben this is absurd
that you didn't bring this to my
attention ben really doesn't do his job
he coasts and all he does is complain
that he has to travel and him and his
wife can't get drunk
all they want to do is get drunk and go
follow colin moricao around
try to fight he's probably dead ben
he wanted to come on the show as the
last thing he could [ __ ] do i'm sure
he had a lot of nice things to say about
me and my comedy and how it's impacted
him before he was killed by russia and
you ruined that i'm scr all my dms are
people threatening to kill me i'm trying
to find and there should be more
hi ben i am from ukraine comedian have
five subs on twitter also if you need
any info i can connect you with
competent people for tim dillon's show
about war i'm following him back i'm
messaging him
i think vladislav is calling me well get
get him on here here uh hello vlad is
live stay rolling on this paul i am uh
at the shelter
uh in kiev and i am trying to find my
way to get guns get wes get helmets
and uh
share them with my friends with my
family so everyone is armed because in
kiev now if you are not
like a armed samurai you're a [ __ ] no
one do you have family in russia you
have friends in russia or because i know
many people in russia have family in
ukraine
is is that the situation or is that not
the case families can't hate each other
if you know
so oh oh i know
oh i know
oh i know very well that they can we
also we
hate our uh own families in ukraine and
if our
family are in russia we hate them even
more and
i agree i hate my own family in long
island and they're they're very close to
me